now if you're in need of some good news
well here is some a 70 year old
grandfather from oldham has rode
3 000 miles across the atlantic ocean
for alzheimer's research
uk frank rothwell joins me now from
antigua frank it's great to see you um
look at you in your shorts and looking
very relaxed
what was it like to finally finish the
that to finish this uh
huge feat
i'm very tired it's a lot it's a long
way and um
i feel really relieved it's all over
and uh we're having a fantastic outcome
um donations to the charity are
exceeding your expectations at the
moment
700 720 000 pounds our target is to
raise
a million pounds and because of people
like yourselves we're
able to do that thank you very much well
that is a huge amount of money
congratulations
and am i right in saying you're the
oldest person to row single-handedly
across the atlantic
yes i'm the oldest person i've got a
couple of world records the
oldest person to raw across the atlantic
and also uh
they always present to do it unaided
with it without assistance
um it took me
56 days and and two hours and
um yeah what's about
don't think you can quite believe it
yourself can you it sounds to me like
you can't even believe it yourself that
you've achieved this
give me some of the the highlights and
the low lights
well the self um
self discipline that's the hardest thing
exactly
you can lay there and drift along with
the wind and the current at one mile an
hour
or you can get under yours and go three
miles everything oh i'm going at three
miles an hour
so um you've got two options so that the
hard thing is
is a self-discipline to keep yourself
going
um obviously i'm i'm an old man with an
old body
so i've got a few adaptions to be bought
to make it
easier for myself my seat is a racing
car seat
rather than a little pad that all those
sits on
and uh so i've got back support
all the time the other door has got a
serious back problems that i'm there
problems at all frank 70 is not old i
won't have you say that
we're looking at pictures now of you uh
in the boat it does look
uh there you are waving fantastic and
you had lots of messages of support
didn't you while you while you were out
on the ocean
i've had fantastic messages of support
from
five over five thousand people have made
donations and everybody's
sent me messages and support i can't
really
identify a single one that's um uh
they're like
the the biggest our best um
i think well i'd like to first of all
i'd like to thank all the 5 000 people
who've
donated and if anybody else wants to
donate it's just just giving
frank rothwell and that's the way to
donate and
we all donations we're glad that we see
for
alzheimer's is a terrible disease my
brother-in-law i had a down syndrome
brother-in-law
who died while i was at sea it was my
inspiration to do to do this you know
roger had difficulty in communicating
and
uh because because of that he didn't
really trigger us that he had
alzheimer's but i'd like to dedicate
this uh this roadmap to
my brother-in-law don't you to roger uh
good for you
and uh your wife was there to greet you
i believe when you finished uh when you
finished
well i've been married 50 years to a
lovely lady called judith
and um i couldn't have done it without
judas support and they're allowing me to
do it because
you know the um you've got to ask your
permission of your wife
if you've made 50 years to do things
like this to go away for
for nearly three months then with
training and setting up and
an actual rowing as well and so without
judas
and her support i phoned her three times
a day and she
mario give me encouragement all the time
i mean well done well done i mean she's
a saint isn't she
for putting up with you and and agreeing
to this oh here she is
here she is what a star you are judith
to put up with this man
what what did you say to him when he
first told you about this
idea of his to to do this massive um
row
um i knew he was coming up to 70
and i knew that he was looking to do a
challenge and
uh when we come across this he says can
i do it i said
yeah he says thank you very much he said
well if i don't whether to do it on my
own or with sunday or with the team i
said no
if you do it with the team it's you and
somebody else
if you do it as seen landed so what
it's you that's raising the money and
it's you that's doing it
yeah well done and what was it like
judith when you spoke to him
um when he was on the high seas and you
called him he must have been
quite low at times was he when things
weren't going quite as they should have
been
he was very um i was very positive with
frank
um sailing around the world it didn't
worry me because i knew that he sailed
in the
dark and always sales is his yacht
in rough seas and you know i knew he had
the um
ability um you know that he
got that fear of the dark and the rough
seas so no it didn't worry me
the nice thing was that he was uh there
was communication
three times you know three times a day
morning afternoon sometimes that night
so communication is a very big relaxing
things
and you know christmas time speaking to
the family
and you know stuff like that was amazing
communications
oh look at it look at him and judith all
this in memory of
roger of course
oh yeah well we've got so many friends
affected by alzheimer's
and you know um you know
young the young sixties you know on
various ages now and it's coming more
and more popular that
the older generation have got
alzheimer's alzheimer's and dementia so
he's very very good cause yeah frank
what was it what was that
being a fantastic i was just going to
ask you frank what was the first thing
you were looking forward to
once you got back to dry land
well the the cool drink
everything on the board is the same
temperature the sea temperature is about
25 degrees
26 degrees and everything you we make
everything out of sea water i have a
water making machine which makes makes
transfers sea water into drinking water
and so
the temperature of everything is that
temperature
i make
[Music]
i make um
foods which are dried fruit just mix it
with water and it comes out that
temperature i never bother cooking
anything just added the water to it
i made the all my drinks were just um
it was what coffee made with cold water
well if you're
going to a cafe and you leave it for
long your coffee goes cold and you still
drink
it
yeah i think i'd like to like to mention
uh
the iceland foods cherishable foundation
whose
match funding old donations to this to
this worthwhile cause
and uh to the value of half a million
pounds and i'd really like to
show my appreciation to the foundation
yeah they've
they've given a big donation haven't
they um well well done
once again frank uh you're an absolute
star uh what a thing to have achieved
at 70 and judith well done for putting
up with him and uh thank you very much
indeed for talking to
us both you're a great couple look at
those look at those muscles
all the best thank you very much indeed
well done